welcome back everybody it's time to take
preventative care seriously
southwest medical has you covered with
all the health screenings you need
as an older adult i spoke with one of
the doctors to find out more
hi dr schroeder welcome to the show
thank you
all right so we're talking about health
screenings for older adults because a
lot of them have been reluctant to
you know getting their proper care
because of cover 19 right
yes that's correct um we've noticed that
since covid we had a downward trend
in our patient numbers most patients
were wanting to stay home for the fear
of covid which we were okay with we
understood that
we started implementing video visits so
that helped a bit but some of our
elderly patients don't have smartphones
or know how to use those kinds of
activities and apps on the phone so we
want them to know that they should still
come to their
doctor's offices we are being very
careful very safe in making sure that we
keep their health and safety first
we've offered some tactics such as what
the cdc
offers with social distancing hand
washing and sanitizing
we only limit the number of patients in
our office to a certain
safe number and they are not allowed to
have anyone come back to the exam room
with them it's only the patient so that
helps as well
we've also required everyone to wear a
mask when they're in the building at all
times and if they leave and re-enter
they go through the same screening
process
of temperature checks screening
questions
and um it's just really important that
they feel safe when they come because we
need them to come especially if they
have chronic medical conditions
exactly and to continue that point
that's why you offer health screenings
right so let's talk about that
sure so health screenings are usually
what we like to do at least once a year
just touch
base with the patient make sure they're
feeling okay these patients typically
don't have anything wrong which is why
they're not typically coming to the
office right now
but it gives the primary care physician
or is the provider a chance to
touch base with the patient examine them
ask questions making sure there's
nothing
underlying that's already sort of
brewing and in progress
preventative care right preventative
care yes getting ahead of things
definitely so if you're on the medicare
advantage plan with southwest medical or
do you get a little extra with these
screenings or how does that work for
people
sure thank you for asking so we offer
wellness checkups
we do ekgs bone mineral density testing
which checks for osteoporosis
very important in the elderly because
they tend to have
balance issues and if that leads to a
fall that can be devastating if they
have osteoporosis that hasn't been
treated or is advanced
we can also check their diabetes by
checking their a1c
we check for circulation and nerve
conduction make sure they don't have
numbness and tingling in their legs that
might
cause them to be more prone to falls
and speaking of falls there are four
areas that older adults really need to
focus on so they can prevent
those types of falls what are those yes
so physical activity even mental
activity is very important the four
things that you're referring to are
endurance
strength balance again to prevent fall
and flexibility
all of those things are so important as
we age
southwest medical associates are they
have locations across southern nevada
just call
or 702-877-5199 smald.com we'll be right
back on las vegas